when I lose my virginity it will be
tender they'll be passionate and I
wanted to be the greatest thing that
she's ever felt do you think he loses
his virginity no I don't think he does
why I think he's gonna wait forever for
what I don't know just to say that he
did do you watch this season I don't
have cable it's a network show it's like
ABC I follow on Twitter that's enough
what are you noticing on Twitter he
makes out a lot on dates they don't
really talk a lot there they make out a
lot yeah how do you think it's not gonna
end up more I think it's gonna end well
I really do you guys talked at all we do
we talk can you send you some some
congrats on this he did he wants to meet
Cory but Cory's like ah that's tender
your eggs that's a little strange but
normal reaction we're all in a good way
have you made up your mind Adam Adam oh
yes mister louder right
so he actually tweeted that I was gonna
be on the episode tonight just to get
yeah so you look about the show pretty
much what is he telling you about the
show he's fully tight-lipped actually he
is he won't tell me he will confirm or
deny anything but what is your suspicion
I think she's gonna be blond early 20
that narrows it down do you think he
ends up with someone I do I think he
does I don't think he did this whole
thing if he wasn't serious about it so
this your first premiere it is
what is working about this relationship
guys I love seeing you here together
um we're long-distance so when we're
together it's really good yeah that's
perfect about every two to three weeks
each other what do you love about this
lady and did you watch her on TV at all
I did not watch her own TV and I didn't
know who she was I was set up actually
through a co-worker of mine and actually
we just get along we're from the country
and we just bond really just of a
southern gent
[Music]